[Música]
en la frontera entre Estados Unidos y
México cientos de personas esperan del
lado mexicano a solucionar su situación
migratoria luego del final del título 42
con las nuevas normas podrían ser
vetados cinco años se cruzan a la Unión
Americana de forma ilegal Tenemos
reporte
Joe biden recibió este viernes al
presidente del gobierno de España Pedro
Sánchez allí hablaron de migración
seguridad y de la guerra en Ucrania
punto en el que ambos confirmaron su
apoyo mutuo en el marco de la alianza
atlántica
la deforestación en la amazonía
brasileña descendió en el mes de abril
en un 68% respecto al mismo periodo del
año anterior una primera Victoria para
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva que busca
acabar con este flagelo en 2030
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano mi
nombre Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos en la frontera
entre México y Estados Unidos a la
medianoche de este jueves se venció el
título 42 que permitía la expulsión
inmediata de inmigrantes alegando
motivos de salud pública en los últimos
días cientos de migrantes se unieron en
la frontera esperando así cruzar hacia
Estados Unidos antes de que entraran en
vigor las nuevas y restrictivas normas
nuestro enviado especial Andrés Suárez
Jaramillo nos contó Cómo transcurrió
este día y a lo largo del día ha
transcurrido todo en calma en calma en
normalidad tanto en el puente
internacional paso del Norte Como en las
diferentes puertas a lo largo de todo el
muro metálico que separa este estado de
Chihuahua con el de Texas los últimos
migrantes que lograron cruzar lo
hicieron por cuenta de la puerta 42 eso
fue durante la noche y durante la la
madrugada en varios autobuses lograron
pasar hasta el paso Texas pero ya hoy no
se registraba mayor movimiento apenas
una veintena de colombianos que
intentaron cruzar entregarse a las
autoridades Ellos están pidiendo que por
favor los cobije el título 42 y no el
título 8 porque alegan de que cruzaron
durante antes de la medianoche pero por
lo pronto se registra mucha normalidad
tranquilidad y no se ha cumplido aquello
de que iban a haber Ríos iban a ver
avalanchas de migrantes en Estados
Unidos un exmarinque estranguló a un
habitante de calle en el metro de Nueva
York fue procesado y acusado de
homicidio involuntario el vídeo de la
muerte de este hombre circuló en las
redes sociales y atrajo la atención
nacional reavivando El Debate sobre la
violencia en los transportes públicos y
sobre el creciente número de personas
sin hogar en la ciudad estadounidense
a primeras horas del viernes el veterano
de la marina estadounidense Daniel Penny
compareció ante el tribunal penal de
Manhattan se enfrenta ahora un cargo de
homicidio en segundo grado dos semanas
después de retener en una asfixia mortal
a Jordan Lili un artista callejero sin
hogar y con antecedentes de enfermedad
mental
Daniel Fénix entregó voluntariamente con
el tipo de dignidad de integridad que
caracteriza su historial de servicio a
esta agradecida nación el caso pasará
ahora a los tribunales el primero de
mayo en el metro de Nueva York Daniel
pini puso a Jordan una llave de
estrangulamiento durante varios minutos
los abogados del ex marine alegaron que
actuó para protegerse a sí mismo y al
resto de las personas presentes en el
tren pero el equipo legal de la familia
de Jordan illi subrayo que según los
Testigos no había atacado a ningún
pasajero
para todos los que dicen yo he estado en
el tren y he pasado miedo antes y no
puedo decirles lo que habría hecho en
esa situación les voy a decir
pregunten Cómo pueden ayudar
por favor no ataques no estrangules no
mates no le quites a alguien un ser
querido porque está en un mal momento el
homicidio y el retraso de la fiscalía en
acusar a Daniel Penny provocaron
protestas los manifestantes señalan
además que giordaniera afro y Daniel
peñez blanco en un país regularmente
marcado por crímenes racistas
entre tanto el presidente de este país
Joe recibió en el despacho baal a su par
español Pedro Sánchez ahí hablaron junto
a otros temas como seguridad y migración
sobre la guerra en Ucrania vaiden
agradeció al presidente español su apoyo
en el conflicto y en materia de
cooperación militar como saben hemos
tenido tres
digamos partes de la conversación en
primer lugar los asuntos globales donde
hemos hablado el largo y extenso sobre
la situación en Ucrania hemos subrayado
la unidad transatlántica y la unidad
también de todos los aliados que
pertenecemos a la otan en nuestro apoyo
a Ucrania en su defensa por la libertad
por su soberanía nacional y el respeto a
la integridad territorial
también hemos recordado que en esta
guerra hay un agresor y hay un agredido
y que aquí el agresor es Putin en
Argentina la inflación es cada vez más
alta y este mes superó cualquier
pronóstico la frágil situación de este
país se ha visto agravada además por una
sequía histórica desde el año pasado
nuestro corresponsal en Buenos Aires
natalio que soy no se amplía
viviendo en Argentina consumiendo bienes
y servicios en el país era difícil
esperar un comportamiento diferente de
la inflación pero este número del 8,4%
de inflación mensual Para abril no deja
de ser impactantes el más alto mensual
desde abril de 2002 más de un 108% de
inflación anual en el mes de abril
también la inflación en alimentos por
ejemplo que es clave porque afecta a los
sectores más pobres Fue de más del 10% y
todo esto además condiciona las
decisiones de los actores económicos en
un escenario de Gran incertidumbre
alimentado también por un contexto de
año electoral en el que el país elegirá
un nuevo presidente Mientras tanto el
ministro de economía Sergio massa se
espera que durante el fin de semana
anuncie medidas para contener la
inflación hay que ver qué ocurre
anteriores medidas que se han tomado no
han logrado frenar la escalada
inflacionaria veremos si en esta ocasión
las medidas que vaya a anunciar
finalmente tienen efecto seguimos con
buenas noticias para la amazonía
brasileña allí la deforestación durante
el mes de abril fue un 68% menor a la
del mismo periodo del año pasado es el
primer gran avance para alucinación Lula
da Silva que quiere acabar con este
flagelo para 2030 pese al positivismo
que arrojan estas cifras los expertos
alertan que aún no se puede hablar de
tendencia
un respiro para la amazonía el mes de
abril supuso una importante reducción en
la pérdida de cobertura vegetal según
los datos del instituto brasileño de
estudios espaciales la deforestación en
abril de este año fue de 329 kilómetros
cuadrados frente a los 1026 de abril de
2022 esto se traduce en una caída de
casi un
68%, además en los cuatro primeros meses
del presente año la deforestación cayó
un 40% respecto al mismo periodo del
estos datos llegan en medio del comienzo
del mandato del presidente Luis Ignacio
violada Silva quien asumió en enero y
tiene como objetivo acabar con la
deforestación para 2030 Brasil señala
que estas cifras pueden tener alguna
relación con ciertas políticas de Lula
como la reestructuración de los órganos
de defensa ambiental Gobierno Federal el
Gobierno Federal reestructuró todo el
área ambiental tenemos el regreso de las
inspecciones
y las operaciones de Mando y control en
la selva se relanzaron recientemente
las políticas de Lula Son drásticamente
opuestas a las de su antecesor Yahir
bolsonaro quien redujo el presupuesto y
el personal en agencias ambientales
claves Bajo su mandato entre 2019 y 2022
la deforestación en la amazonía aumentó
un 60%, ahora los expertos aseguran que
las cifras de 2023 No son suficientes
para hablar de una tendencia y habrá que
esperar al periodo entre julio y
septiembre cuando se registra el pico
anual de deforestación
y vamos a cerrar esta informativo
hablando con nuestra compañera eumar
esaa sobre lo que ha acontecido con Leo
Messi y el psg parece que vuelve a los
entrenamientos y al equipo Sí el técnico
Christopher te confirmó que cuenta con
él como titular para el partido este
sábado contra el ayaxo la necesidad
obliga y el psg necesitaba de vuelta a
su Astro argentino que estaba sancionado
recordemos por dos partidos debido a un
viaje no autorizado ahora vía Saudita
sin embargo esta semana ya entrenó de
nuevo con el equipo cumplió solamente la
mitad de su sanción
una sanción que quizás se ha cortado un
poquito por ese vídeo que vimos de Leo
Messi pidiendo perdón después también de
que se lo asociará al Gil al de Arabia
Saudita No eumar sí de ese viaje
justamente salió el rumor de que
supuestamente se había hecho una oferta
de 400 millones de dólares para que el
Leo Messi se sumara al al que es el
campeón dirigido por un técnico
argentino Ramón Díaz Pero esto fue
desmentido por el padre de Messi a
través de un comunicado claro y habría
sido interesante allí porque se podría
haber encontrado con otro Astro con
Cristiano Ronaldo no está viviendo
tampoco su equipo el mejor momento pero
hay que hablar de una cosa importante y
es que el psg es propiedad de Qatar
también la geopolítica entraba aquí
claro recordemos que el Leo Messi es el
embajador turístico de Arabia Saudita y
bueno obviamente entra en conflicto con
el tema el hecho de que el psg sea de
propiedad catari bueno Omar pues
Seguiremos muy atentos a lo que pase con
Messi Muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros en este informativo yo les
agradezco también que hayan estado con
nosotros y sigan con más en France 24
[Música]